This testimony's powerful. I was 11
years old when I picked up my first
habit. I ended up getting addicted to
opiates. I got arrested at the age of 17
for seven felony charges. The judge told
me, "You can either do 10 years or we're
going to have to send you to a program
for your addiction issues." So,
obviously, I chose the program. I met
Pastor Mike and his wife, [music] Cindy.
They told me the gospel of Jesus Christ.
When I heard the gospel of Jesus Christ
and what he did for me, I cried, you
know, and then within that first 4
months when I was at that addiction
center, I felt the Holy Spirit come into
my life and I never felt more grace,
more peace, more accepted. I didn't feel
alone anymore, you know, I finally felt
like I found the answer to that empty
feeling that I've been feeling my whole
childhood and when I lost my friend, all
of the Christianity went out the window.
I turned my back on God. I despised God.
I made it a point that it was all God's
fault. I got two DUIs. I overdosed a
couple times. I attempted to take my own
life as well and throughout that whole
entire time, God was still with me, you
know. I just didn't realize it. My
pancreas was starting to fail and some
of my organs were not great. Times I
could barely breathe. I was not eating.
I was malnourished. I had like red spots
all over my face. I would literally be
so messed up that I would just like nod
out in the middle of like conversations
and stuff and it was just it was bad.
The music thing was doing good. Like
everything in the world was doing good.
My stream numbers were up. When we got
home, he sat me down. He said, "Hey,
man, I just want you to know that I love
you. I just want you to know that
watching you do this to yourself every
single day and knowing that you're going
to die because of it really sucks." And
then he walked out. And he left me with
that.
That was the last straw for me. I was
ready to give up for real, you know, and
and I looked up to God and I said, "You
know what, man? I don't want it anymore.
If you're real, just please take this
away from me. Like I'm begging you.
I don't want to feel this pain anymore.
I hate myself." I heard God literally
tell me,
"Don't put that music back up.
You don't make secular music anymore.
[music] You make music for me."
I told everyone that I was done and I
lost millions of streams, tens of
thousands of followers, thousands of
dollars. People cussed me out. They were
like, "How are you just going to abandon
your fans like that? We had such a
connection and now all of it's gone."
The things of this world pass. I
surrendered my life fully to Jesus
Christ. I don't want to be the person
that I used to be. And [music] the only
reason that I've gotten this far and
that I've been able to do the things
that I have is because God has given me
the strength. God has given me the
vision. So,
he deserves all the praise. Every single
song that I make now will praise Jesus.
I will not do secular music anymore and
regardless of what comes with that, I
feel peace now for the first time in my
life. Real peace. I feel no doubt that
I'm walking in the right direction. If
you're struggling with any type of
drugs, if you're struggling with any
type of alcohol, man, this is Jesus
telling you that it's time, bro. Like
you've waited long enough. You're not
worthless. I gave up and I'm made new
through Christ.